today i'm going to talk about getting
into the culture
[Music]
hi there steve kaufman here and today
i'm going to talk about
you know getting into the culture
of the language that we are learning
uh remember if you like these videos
please subscribe click on the bell to
get notifications and come and join me
at link to learn languages
now in my last video i talked about the
need to want to sort of penetrate that
other cultural world to not hang back
when you're with people from that
language group but also i think
part of that is to
want to learn about that language group
about their culture their history
as you may realize i like learning
languages it's kind of my hobby there
are people who go skiing all the time i
like to ski but i don't go that often
people who go fly fishing and i like
learning languages
so
when i go after a language i also buy
books
so i finished my 90-day challenge in
arabic
and i did show you some of the books
that i had bought for arabic but not
only did i buy books about the language
you know
spoken standard arabic here uh
you know advanced media arabic these i'm
going to get at these the travels of ibn
batuta they're all too difficult for me
modern arabic short stories i tend to go
you know wild you see
indulging my interest i also got this
book about the history of cairo which
was fascinating in english of course i'm
not going to show you all these
history of the arab peoples so that's
kind of my i'm indulging my interest in
things related to
arabic and the arab world well i'm off
arabic now for the time being go back to
it it's there i've got it it's on the
back burner it's it's somebody it's like
an old friend i can go back to and renew
my relationship whenever i want but now
i've decided to move on to persian
so
uh
what have i got here uh not only have i
got this i've started reading this
history of iran
and uh
also in link
we have um you know sahra in in iran has
created the series of 26 episodes which
i'm now going through i've gone to
episode seven
uh of the history of iran with a
circling question so i'm listening to
that
learning about the uh
i guess i have so much trouble with that
word the asha mendes has
or
whatever uh
sheed you know persepolis and all this
kind of stuff and so i learned it i hear
it in uh persian i look up the words
and then i'm going to be reading about
it in this book in english which is a
little easier but it's all part of
engaging with the culture
she has also created a series on uh
iranian or persian food persian carpets
uh the different ethnic groups in iran
all of these are separate um you know
courses that she's created
and of course we have the series the
iranians where
um
[Music]
you know we hear different people in
iran talk about their lives and what
they do and things of that nature so
that gradually i'm sort of getting into
it and and it is so fascinating because
the fact is that in our education system
in canada which is probably similar in
in the western world we don't learn a
lot about let's take iran or persia
uh what we know of persia is they were
the bad guys
where at the battle of marathon
and the greeks were the good guys
and yet you read about the history of
persia and you realize that 2500 years
ago
you have this very enlightened ruler
cyrus
kurosh
who had a
sort of a almost like a magna carta of
rights and privileges for
different religions different ethnic
groups after he captured babylon
whenever that was roughly 2500 years ago
we read i read
you know sakura mentions it in her
[Music]
in her series on the history of iran and
it also comes up in the book i'm reading
that 2500 years ago
and and really throughout the history of
iran up until the arrival of islam
women had a very high status in persian
society uh we're often senior managers
were allowed to travel alone on business
and
and in fact they were they got extra pay
like they worked and they got extra pay
when they had you know or burying
children and and this kind of thing and
pay in many cases was extra food and
whatever
so it's interesting to explore this
i mean persian and and also to
understand that there was this whole
world
which if you look at the map
so persia iran persia not only was
baghdad and large parts of sort of
mesopotamia
which originally was
and sumer
that was part of the whole persian world
you know the i guess the border moved
back and forth
uh
when baghdad became
sort of
the capital of the sort of arabic
um caliphate in in what today is iraq
that capital was right next to what used
to be a persian capital and so you
follow then the persians up north of the
caspian sea
uh
east through afghanistan where half the
population speaks today some form of
persian
and of course the intermingling of
persians with
turkish speakers in central asia
persian influence on india i mean
there's this whole world there
that we're kind of unaware of
and and the same is true of course of
the arabic world
uh
you know taking egypt from
pre-islam
through when they were you know they had
the greek and roman influence there and
and uh through you know and therefore we
have the coptic christians and stuff
there's so much history there that we
don't hear about we only learn about
western europe the kings of england
you know and all this kind of stuff you
know the explorers that discovered
canada and and
you know
developed the fur trade uh which is
important to canada but
all i the point i wanted to make was i
mean i could show you oh one other thing
i do buy grammar books so i katie leaf
through this uh persian grammar
and it typically refers to things that
i'm already familiar with and therefore
helps to kind of suck it in a bit
but
learning languages is indulging an
interest
and exploring the world
discovering the world which we do both
in the language in the case of these uh
you know the course on say history and
other things that relate to persian
culture that sahara has created for us
at link but even beyond that
reading about the history in english
which is easier for me
and eventually one day traveling to the
country and exploring some of these
places exploring persepolis and shiraz
and
whatever all the things there are to see
in
in iran and of course when you read
about it then i can remember feeling the
same way when i was learning japanese to
want to explore more parts of japan and
learn more about the country or france
or china or russia or any place so
language learning is kind of like
a key
that opens the door to all kinds of
interesting things
that broaden
our
sense of the world we live in
and also give us a better understanding
of different cultures and therefore
makes it easier for us
to sympathize with that culture and
penetrate that culture so i just wanted
to follow up my
last video where i talked about the need
to sort of force your way into this
the culture or the in-group of the
language you're learning
but also there's many things you can do
on your own
to bring that world to life for you so
there you have it just thought i would
talk about that today bye for now
[Music]